so one of the things I think you do
incredibly well is you play the
supporting character the brother the
brother-in-law the friend and you just
make the most out of a supporting
character out of a small amount of
screen time so what do you think is the
key to making an impression in a role
like that is it
it's from the Bernie Mac schooler actor
that you learned that no role is small
you know it's like every time you it's
so funny then I bring that bring him up
because you know a lot of the smaller
stuff he did before he started to lead
his stuff you couldn't forget about it
I'll keep it as one or two scenes or
just like you wouldn't fit so like I try
to do everything where you remember that
I'm in this movie very successfully and
it's always from a place of so much
heart and support for the rest of the
characters so I feel like I don't know
everyone needs a version of you in their
life I like this like reuniting with
McKeithen Issa after moonlight getting
back in the room together was it kind of
just like a step away from that or had
you guys kept in touch
well like get outcasts we like you know
we're close I guess really because that
was all our big break
so yeah we hang out so but it was good
to get back on you know on camera which
it's not gonna be our last reunion which
is crazy this year oh I like to hear
that yeah I'm trying to think of what
that could be
does it have to do with I mean you bad
trip coming up right yeah as what Eric
Andre Tamia Tiffany every union that
Tiffany Haddish but I'm really looking
forward to that one yeah I'm a big
sucker for that kind of prank right
right now these are like that's one of
the tough is I don't know if I ever do
it again which is scare if it's really
successful whether you have to kill my
kid because this is so those are real
reactions with people and you don't know
how they're going to react to there and
it's kind of it's fun and it's also
frightening I have to ask one more
question about that movie where any of
the pranks situations that ever made you
think you know maybe we're going too far
with this
yeah the first day you know wait wait
till we go net press to her like because
it was it was you're getting real
reactions and if you don't have the
security in the right place so it can
the first day was one of the craziest
first days of anything above almost quit
because it was it was in because you
don't know how somebody got yeah so this
movie puts a lot of importance on a
single photograph and the meaning in the
history behind it but to photograph
questions for you one on your phone what
is the photo that you have the most of
like a selfie is it pet photos food
photos what is it Mia my keys yeah it's
a good answer to that is the
straightaway yeah they look cool we take
really cool pictures as a family and do
you have a most important photo my most
important photo you know it's the most
important photo is in this interest I've
taken a picture this recently is my
parents wedding photo from 70s it
because it's such a unique look by
everybody it is like unlined froze and
the big sideburns like this these suits
with the big bow ties you know my
grandfather did wedding you know you can
see my cousin there's a little kids like
the oldest cuz it's just such a
beautiful they don't even look real
actually that's how beautiful it looks
but it was thinking about that moment I
look at the photo all the time like yo
that was real life at once at like who's
not we do all these nostalgic things and
movies and stuff where we try to reenact
things but like no this is there